It’s tough to know how we might respond
to a true disaster.
What might any of us do when the world turns
upside down, and nothing makes sense anymore?
What if the simple act of stepping outside
into the sunlight became the deadliest thing
in the world?
We’ve delved into this horrifying notion
before with SCP-001, “When Day Breaks”,
or S.D.
Locke’s Proposal.
One of the most nightmarish XK-Class End of
the World Scenarios ever devised.
Mr. Rogers once said that the best thing to
do in times of trouble is “Look to the helpers.”
No matter how dire things become, there will
always be those taking up the difficult work
of putting their community back together.
Firefighters, emergency medical services,
soup kitchens, there are so many different
kinds of helpers out there.
Unfortunately, most of them would be the first
to go once the sun’s rays turned on us all.
The firefighter attempting to put out a blaze
would melt into a puddle of goo.
The EMT running out of an ambulance would
melt the second his feet hit the pavement.
When doom and destruction are everywhere,
who is left to help?
Perhaps someone who has always dreamed of
saving humanity from a great plague, but is
trapped inside with no sunlight in sight.
When the whole world has grown sick, humanity
forever changed into something terrible, we
just might need a Doctor.
Today, we’re looking at what happens when
a dedicated physician meets his greatest challenge
yet.
We’ve discussed SCP-049 many times before.
He is a humanoid entity, standing roughly
1.9 meters in height, resembling a man dressed
in the garb of a Medieval plague doctor.
He is clad in thick dark robes and a ceramic
mask that tapers into a long, sharp beak.
Though it may look like a costume, these adornments
are actually a part of the entity’s body.
SCP-049 wants one thing: to cure humankind
of a mysterious pestilence, the nature of
which has never been entirely clear.
Sadly, his work tends to do more harm than
good.
He can kill with a single touch, and his attempts
to cure human subjects result in malformed
zombies instead.
He carries around a black doctor’s bag capable
of holding an impossible amount of medical
implements, which he uses to perform his work.
Though his actions tend to result in more
harm than good, the Plague Doctor seems to
genuinely care about his patients, their well-being,
and curing them of the illness he believes
to be ravaging their bodies.
049 is singular in his obsession with eradicating
the plague he so often speaks of, and he will
not stop until he has done so.
But what does a doctor do, when there are
no more patients left to treat?
When humanity has been wiped out, and the
Pestilence is gone for good?
Let’s peek in on the doctor in his containment
cell and see what he’s up to?
It appears that he’s working on something,
or perhaps it’s better to say… someone.
But what is this new creation?
It looks too small to be a human, too human-like
to be an animal, it looks too much…
like him?
Has it finally happened?
Has the Plague Doctor begun to reproduce himself?
It seems the answer is yes, but not in the
way you might think, since it appears what
he has created is a plush version of everyone’s
favorite masked malady man!
That’s right, the Plague Doctor has created
something special, and now for the first time,
you can have a Plague Doctor of your very
own by going to SCP Swag dot com and ordering
one right now!
And with this one you don’t have to worry
about waking up to find that you’ve been
converted into a walking zombie-like shell
of your former self.
No, this nearly ten inch tall plush which
comes complete with his own removable doctor's
bag, is a soft, squeezable version of the
SCP-049 that we all know and love or fear.
Put him on your shelf, carry him with you
in your own bag, or set him on your desk so
you always have someone to discuss your own
theories of what exactly the Pestilence is.
We just can’t promise that he’ll divulge
any secrets, since this little Plague Doctor
seems especially tight lipped.
We know you’ll love him as much as we do
though, so go to SCP Swag dot com and order
one for yourself right now.
Supplies are limited so don’t wait!
But back to the taller, and more mobile Plague
Doctor…
The Doctor sat in his containment cell, as
he did every other day of his captivity, doing
his best to keep busy.
The scientists of the SCP Foundation were
small-minded, they did not comprehend the
gravity of his work, the necessity of ridding
the world of the Pestilence.
He forgave them for their ignorance, for they
did not know what they were doing.
Instead, he kept his mind on the goal, the
duty he had as a physician and a man of the
sciences.
Just as many scientists had done in the past
when their work was unappreciated, Copernicus
was persecuted for his model of the universe
and his knowledge that the earth revolved
around the sun, Jonas Salk for his controversial
invention of the polio vaccine that saved
countless lives, SCP-049 would be remembered
fondly by history for his contributions.
Even if his contemporaries did not understand
his vision.
And so, in spite of the suspicion and doubt
that surrounded him at this Foundation that
should have been all for groundbreaking research,
the Doctor carried on with his work.
He sat on the floor of the cell, his bag open
next to him.
From its endless interior, he withdrew syringes,
bottles of viscous liquids, tissue samples
suspended in jars, and a stainless steel table
upon which he could place it all.
Today, he would perform a new round of tests
on samples he had been able to extract from
previous patients before he was thrown into
this unjust imprisonment.
These doctors, men he had once viewed as colleagues,
had not brought him a new test subject in
quite some time.
A guard had muttered something about it being
“too costly” to keep “wasting perfectly
good cows” on him.
Simpletons, fools, luddites beating their
fists against their own chests in the face
of true progress.
Their small minds were of no concern to him.
The Doctor placed his tools on his work table
and began to take out the samples.
An ear, a piece of skin taken from the bottom
of a foot, a section of a liver, and, most
exciting of all: the frontal lobe of a human
brain.
Indeed, it would be a fruitful day of investigation
into the mysteries of The Great Dying.
He was just pulling a scalpel from his bag
when his concentration was suddenly interrupted
by the sound of a blaring siren.
He set his tools down and looked up.
That sound…it signified trouble at the facility.
But surely it would be over soon, once the
issue had been dealt with.
Outside his cell, he could hear the thundering
footsteps of guards running past, shouting
at one another too quickly for him to understand.
One man stopped to peer into 049’s cell,
making sure he was still contained, most likely.
“My good fellow!”
The Doctor called out, reminding himself to
speak in the King’s English so the man could
understand.
“Would you be so kind as to enlighten me…what
is the trouble?
If anyone has been injured, I would be happy
to offer my assistance…”
The man did not respond, his attention grabbed
by something further down the hall that the
Doctor could not see.
“Wait!”
He cried, but the guard had already disappeared.
The siren continued to blare, assaulting his
senses with its shrill tone.
In the distance, he could hear screams.
Surely, there was a dire situation at hand.
Had that damnable reptile escaped again?
He approached the door to his cell, listening
for further information.
There was no roaring, no sounds of walls crumbling.
There was only that blasted alarm, and screams
of unadulterated fear and agony.
Very curious, and quite troubling.
SCP-049 tried to open the door, knowing that
it was futile.
He had never been able to escape before, why
would that change now?
Still, a scientist must repeat his efforts
in order to gather new data.
So, he thrust his shoulder against the door,
attempting to break it down.
It did not budge.
Instead, an automatic containment measure
was triggered, releasing lavender-scented
gas into the room in an attempt to calm the
Doctor down.
He did love the scent, it reminded him of
gentler times long ago.
He took a deep breath, imagining fields of
purple flowers swaying in a summer breeze.
That was the world he fought for, not the
flawed human beings that opposed him, not
this sterile facility packed with the ignorant.
For now, he would return to the work.
If they did not desire his help, there was
nothing more to be done.
Sometime later, perhaps hours, perhaps days,
he could not be certain when there was no
sunlight to gauge the time by, the alarm fell
silent.
The Doctor stopped his ministrations and listened.
As the alarm had stopped, so too had the screams.
In fact, the whole facility seemed to have
gone completely, eerily silent.
“Hello?”
He called out, but there was no response,
save for a clicking sound.
Now, that was a sound he had heard before.
Normally, it signified the arrival of armed
guards who would strap him into a harness,
knock him out, and take him somewhere else.
It was the sound of the door to his containment
cell unlocking.
But there was no one there.
Could it be…?
Grabbing his faithful bag, SCP-049 cautiously
pushed against the door.
It swung open, revealing a darkened, vacant
hallway.
Gone were the harsh fluorescent lights, the
D-Class personnel mopping blood stains off
the floors, the doctors hurrying by with clipboards
in hand.
Everyone was gone.
From what he could see, at least.
He would have to investigate further in order
to know for sure.
A scientist never assumes until they have
all of the available information, after all.
So, SCP-049 walked the halls of the seemingly
abandoned Foundation site, expecting to be
interrupted at any moment by an adversary
in a white coat who would usher him back to
his prison.
But the interruption never came.
As he rounded the corner past one of the containment
facilities, a familiar voice called out to
him.
“Excuse me!
Please, could you help me?
Open the door!”
049 stopped and peered into the room.
It was the Possessive Mask’s room, SCP-035.
The Doctor opened the door and there it was,
the porcelain mask grinning at him from its
glass case.
Thick black liquid oozed from its eyes and
wide-open mouth.
“Oh wonderful, it’s you!”
The mask gleefully enthused.
“My good man, you gentleman and scholar,
would you please release me from this awful
case?”
049 paused, considering the potential ramifications
of this action.
“No doubt you’ve noticed that things have
changed around here.”
The mask continued.
“The Foundation is different now…the old
rules have gone out the window.”
“Hmm, so it would seem.”
The Doctor replied.
“I will not wear you, understood?
I will only release you from your cage.”
“And for that I will be eternally grateful!”
The mask promised.
The Doctor approached the glass case in several
quick strides, and, with one gloved fist,
broke through the glass.
“Thank you, old friend!”
The mask cried out.
“Now, take me with you!”
The Doctor shook his head.
“I have more pressing matters to attend
to at the moment.
If it is true, if they have all gone…Then
this facility is in dire need of a new head
researcher.”
At his words, the mask’s visage changed,
the cheerful smile warping into an exaggerated
frown.
“And you think you’re the man for the
job?
How embarrassing.
How truly…tragic.”
“Bite your tongue!”
The Doctor retorted.
“Ah, but I don’t have one.
Some physician you are!”
The mask taunted.
Unwilling to deal with the porcelain fiend’s
naysaying any longer, the Doctor turned and
swept out of the room.
Now was not the time for such verbal sparring,
he had so much to do.
This whole facility could be his new workshop,
his laboratory, and he would need assistants
to help him manage it.
But who was qualified enough, loyal to the
cause, armed with sharp wit and a body free
of Pestilence?
As he made his way through the pitch black
halls, he felt something nudge his leg.
He glanced down, uncertain what he would find,
and saw a teardrop-shaped orange creature
nudging him affectionately, gazing up at him
with one large unblinking eye.
Next to his other leg, a mustard yellow creature
the same shape and size was rolling toward
him.
“Are you friend or foe?”
The Doctor asked.
The creatures continued to nudge against his
legs, seeming to want something.
Attention, perhaps?
He bent down and patted each creature gently.
They rolled around his feet in circles, making
a delighted babbling sound.
“Ah, companion it is.
Well then, come along.”
As he continued along his path, the little
creatures rolled after him, keeping close
to his heels.
Suddenly, they began to babble loudly, in
a panicked tone, swarming around the front
of his feet as if to stop him.
“Is there a danger here, my ocular friends?”
The Doctor asked.
From the cell up ahead, a voice cried out
in French.
“Help!
Please!
I’m so hungry!”
The Doctor rushed to the door, opening it
to reveal a behemoth of a man with a large,
rounded chin and jaw, and deep-set eyes that
peered down at him.
The man grinned at the Doctor with impossibly
large teeth.
“Thank you, Sir!
I was sure I would die in there.”
As he stepped out into the light, the Doctor
could see this giant was dressed in a military
uniform.
“Are you a military man?”
The Doctor asked.
“Yes, I was a soldier in the French army
once.”
The giant replied.
“Before I became the greatest detective
the world has ever known.”
The Doctor clapped his hands delightedly,
his eyes glittering from within his mask.
“Intelligence and loyalty, not to mention
strength!
You, my good man, are everything I have been
searching for!
Would you do me the honor of working as my
assistant?
I have a great deal of research to do, and
could make use of a man with your many talents.”
The giant tipped his hat politely to the Doctor.
“It would be my honor, Sir.
You may call me Fernand.”
He reached out for a handshake, but the Doctor
shook his head.
“It would be best if I did not.
But it is a pleasure to make your acquaintance!”
He glanced down at the eye pods, still skittering
about anxiously.
“See, there is nothing to fear here.”
“Unless I don’t find something to eat
soon…”
Fernand quipped.
And so the Doctor continued along his way,
with Fernand and his new pets in tow.
This was an excellent advancement, but he
would need a great deal more help if he was
to effectively run the Foundation.
He recruited two other anomalies with a mind
for scientific research: a small bird with
a deafening voice, and a doctor himself, and
an eloquent sea slug with years of hunting
and adventuring experience.
It was a relief to find fellow intellectuals
here.
As the ever-increasing band of anomalies approached
the basement, Fernand perked up noticeably.
“Something smells…wonderful.
Just beyond this door!”
Fernand opened the door, and led the group
into a treasure trove of corpses.
They had found the Foundation’s morgue.
Rows and rows of drawers filled with test
subjects, and food for Fernand.
It was everything the Doctor could have possibly
wanted.
“My dear Fernand, take as many as you can
carry and follow me to the laboratory!”
The Doctor declared.
“Tally ho!”
Cried the slug.
“Cack!
And how!”
Dr. Spanko added.
The Doctor set up shop in one of the many
expansive on-site labs.
Though the electricity was out, he could still
get a great deal of use out of it.
There was so much more space in here, so many
more resources than his tiny cell had!
Within a matter of hours, he had set up a
row of IVs pumping out his serums into test
subjects, reanimating them into more lab assistants.
The newly revived corpses shambled around
the lab, bringing him bone saws and forceps,
vials and needles of all sizes, as the Doctor
worked harder than he had in years.
The others were less help than he had hoped,
but with so many newly treated patients to
share the workload he hardly noticed.
All of these poor souls, victims of the Pestilence
no doubt, and he had all the time in the world
now to cure them.
Before long, the once-vacant halls of the
Foundation were filled with the slow plodding
footsteps of his patients, dragging their
swollen limbs across the ground, blinking
their milky white eyes at the chaos outside
the windows of the facility.
As 049 was absorbed in his work, the rest
of the escaped anomalies began to realize
that their freedom had come at a cost.
Where there had once been friendly yellow
sunlight beaming down on a lush green world,
there was now an angry red fire in the sky,
and a landscape covered in strange gelatinous
masses, roving and oozing and moaning as one.
They had escaped from their cells, but they
were still trapped.
Their prison had just gotten larger.
The Doctor had not yet noticed this unfortunate
truth, so focused was he on treating the patients
they had recovered from the morgue.
At least, the ones that had not been given
to Fernand to satisfy his mammoth appetite.
However, a week later, the Doctor was horrified
to discover that there were no more corpses
left, no more patients to cure.
He stood in the empty morgue, looking from
drawer to drawer for just one body they had
missed, proof that his work was not over so
soon.
“What’s the matter, Doctor?”
A sardonic voice behind him said.
He turned to find SCP-035, attached to the
face of a mannequin.
“I see you procured a body.”
He noted.
“No thanks to you.”
The mask replied.
“Oh, how sad.
A Doctor with no one to treat.
What will you do now that you have no purpose
in life?
I wonder…”
“There will be more.”
The Doctor insisted.
“There is an entire world out there that
needs my help.”
The mask laughed in disbelief.
“You mean you haven’t noticed?
There is no world left to help.
It’s all gone to hell.
Take a look for yourself.”
The Doctor rushed to an upstairs window and
gazed down at the destruction outside.
The painful red sunlight, the rubble where
there once were buildings, the masses of soft,
gooey matter that aimlessly squelched along
the ground.
“No…”
He put a hand to his beak, shaking his head.
“It can’t be…”
“But it is.”
Said the mask, standing behind him.
Its face was locked in a grin, delighted to
see him suffering so.
“Your life’s mission, gone…just like
that.”
The Doctor’s knees went weak as he tried
to take it all in.
Perhaps the mask was right, he had no purpose
anymore…
But then, Fernand’s voice boomed from below.
“Doctor!
We need your assistance downstairs!
Quickly!”
The Doctor followed his assistant’s cries
and saw what was so urgent: one of the blob
creatures, an entity he knew must have once
been a human being, had found its way inside
the facility.
Fernand stood back from it, afraid to touch
its slimy surface.
But SCP-049 did not see a monster there, oozing
across the floor.
He saw someone who was sick, desperately ill,
and in need of help.
In need of a Doctor.
“Do not be afraid, my friend.”
He sat down his bag, and reached inside, as
his reanimated helpers swarmed around the
blob creature.
“You are not well, but I am going to help
you.”
The Great Dying may have been out of his grasp,
but if the scene outside the window was anything
to go on, there was still a plague raging
across the earth.
And he was going to find the cure.
Don’t forget, go to SCP Swag dot com to
order a Plague Doctor plush of your very own!
That’s SCP Swag dot com.
Then go check out “SCP-049 – The Plague
Doctor” and “When Day Breaks SCP-096”
for more on The Plague Doctor, and what happened
to another SCP after day finally broke.